what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to start She-Hulk today
yeah and of course John how are you doing I am
great I'm so excited koi it's been a while since
you've been in a video with us we'll go check
out Corey's comic Corner maybe have theories
coming out for this episode today follow
him on Tick Tock where he's got 15 second
to three minutes I hear your intros I edit
them so he'll say it Corey I'm expecting you
to bring your comic expertise whenever there's
a character that pops up on screen you better
instantly name them or else you don't know Comics
first appearance name Alias and Adventure leave a
like Hulk smash that like button also subscribe
and click that notification Bell to get notified
when our reaction for the next She-Hulk is
up also full-length Reaction watch Longs we
need to sync up with your own copier over at
our patreon page for super sexy rejects cover
some shows exclusively over there with the same
tier you get the option for reaction highlights
watch along is included lastly prepper well
thank you guys so much for helping us these
down koi show them your triceps triceps prepper
now the other one's a lot bigger that's still
pretty big nice I'm really white Greg I know it
affects you you're gonna get a tan let's do this
the defendant used their Limitless resources for
financial gain at the expense of Public Safety
your litigator that their power shielded them
from very real consequences shielded and you
and the case and you are not helpful here Adam
but I will kill you and general prosecute only
because it's a conflict of interest not because
I condone murder you're going to listen to a
paralegal over another lawyer he means a woman
over a man I almost cried during parts of it
now you just have to top it off with a Savage
Jen Walters look what I don't have a Savage
Jen Walters ah Savage She-Hulk reference it's
it's good I picked up on that too it's subtle
they only said it twice um it's
true I am a Hulk uh and I'm guessing
I'm guess I'm gonna be able to focus on this
fun lawyer show until you know all about that so
immediate fourth wall break Cheetos
and Chopsticks yeah so you don't get
don't get stuff back to what I
was saying before my theory oh god
um Steve Rogers let's let's all act
like we haven't hurt seen this scene yet
everything that I've already told you about
my friend and golly obviously Captain America
that's your ship from zakar right yeah
ouch kind of felt that there inhibitor
oh my god
wow that was such a fast transformation yeah
oh girl what happened to you are you okay okay no
judgments but whoever did this
to you does not care about you
I have to call my cousin to get me
can I borrow somebody's phone we
all deserve a squad like this one the
friendliest little bar hey we're just
being friendly yeah you too good to talk
to us damn you guys are aggressive foreign
fixing myself and integrating
the Hulk Banner identities
in this tiny Beach House lab yeah yeah Tony built
it for me a few years ago Tony Stark do we hit a
spaceship yeah it's a car in class A couriercraft
they're probably trying to deliver a message I got
to get to the bottom of that you know weird
stuff just kind of found you a girl foreign
I've been analyzing your blood and the
way it synthesized gamma I was able to
use it to completely heal my arm because I'm
better than you um it's basically different
my arm is healed and now I'm able to
be my fully integrated self again smug
I just got my own office I have business cards
there is no going back to what you were before
oh
Man Hulk looks great yeah I'm
like that [__] in end game right
just stay here until you you figure out how to
control your Hulk self well how long is that
gonna take about 15 years give or take 15 years
top priorities to control when you turn foreign
Jacks in
put on a Pixar movie when Bing Bong jumps
out even he was like triggers are anger and
fear they're like the Baseline of any woman
just existing all right then let's try this
hmm dark Tech feels like if I don't
transform I'm gonna die do you have
a plan B for that uh no this is gonna
kill me they go die make your choice
yes
laughs wait wait you're still you're still
gen right now yeah you're the only only one
in there as far as I can tell this is huge and
I think I'm jealous is that what I'm feeling
this time it was so intense I could barely
remember what was happening but it's like it's
settled in hmm well you can just skip all that
then how do I turn back into Jen how did you do it
I think I'd fall out of a jet or I get knocked
out by a robot and I'd wake up his Banner
Natasha for a little while would tell me a lullaby
walk me through how that worked again
I don't have a great explanation for it
just regular anger means death and Destruction for
everything and everyone around you and I'm telling
you when people start seeing you as a monster
that never goes away wow teach me how to Hulk
please teach me how to hook to teach me how
to Hulk first we're going to practice some
mindfulness with a few yoga techniques
it's more about presence about accepting
the situation you're in Oh I thought it
was about getting my butt tight as hell
gross Jen and your cousin just close
your eyes and breathe all right
who's your best friend Mickey spandex
just trying to show you how it's done
asks for balance
laughs
it's easy
all right all I've been doing is showing you
the downsides of being a hawk but there are
a few upsides my body's metabolize alcohol
that we can drink so much and knock it drunk
yeah the Hulk's an alcoholic
I mean kind of impressive yeah me and Tony
not Tony mostly drank just sat around like
complaining about Steve oh Steve ah this
is ruining the post Civil War time yeah
when do you think I can't believe let's
just focus on each day as they come Jim
cat called in the street when incompetent
Men explain my own area of expertise to
me so all of this just feels like
projecting a lot of [__] onto me
no I'm doing this oh okay this
is completely new territory
I bet that little thing she was lamenting is gonna
go over well with everybody oh I bet a lot of this
is gonna go everybody yeah the show in general is
going to be below you're now a superhero and who's
gonna protect the world if it isn't People Like
Us are you quoting a comic book right now laughs
I'm serious you're not the only one
but you think you can just say a
bunch of me things like that and then take off yes
did I kill the Hulk
oh here we go
damn Bruce for the record I
really didn't want to do this
oh Thunderclap that's all you got
get that nut
oh no not the bar
so if you want to go back to
life as a lawyer I respect that
something wrong with me she's kind of hot as
the Hulk oh no I've definitely got a thing
call me anytime thank you Bruce thanks very much
a breaker's mine I'm sorry that I said a
bunch of harsh but very very apology that
still doubles down on a thing you're apologizing
I've seen that horoscope meme a thousand times
I see a fuzzball
I really like them together I like her a lot too
I was right and Bruce was wrong and I never have
to be a Hulk okay so now I'm gonna go in this case
ladies and gentlemen of the
jury oh my God early entrance
I really love that delivery
Jennifer Walters attorney at law
mm-hmm
I'm ready to give my closing argument now foreign
where's Daredevil you know he'll be
the lead soon I thought he was the
star looks like they set up
that uh World War Hulk movie
yeah I think uh we might see other
characters like looking for Hulk games
you mean the ship from sakhar it's a car yeah I
wonder if someone's looking for a new champion
or it could be a son you think he did
they do him scar banged in the last two
years come on man that's why they set it
up with the Captain America virgin thing
she's like a la based hero we need them
I don't know if I learned that
oh my God we gotta postgres sex
deserve to die virgin Steve Rogers is not
a virgin he lost his virginity little girl
in 1943 on the USO tour knew it
you're not drunk Captain America
Natalie Dormer [__] Captain America
all time girls one of the best currencies
I don't care what anyone says
that was one of the best songs
thank you so good I said uh trailer reaction
I was like I bet he bones someone during World
War II right yeah I was thinking right back
to that chat we have the Natalie Dormer scene
I I feel like they boned the girl who was
hitting on him in front of Peggy yeah yeah
let's only talk about that all right
Captain America this totally changes
the Integrity of his character I thought he was
a dedicated Christian way until marriage yeah
corner
coil comic corner post coitus
now we'll find out that Sam is actually
the virgin of the Captain America yeah
all right well I enjoyed it I enjoyed it um I
think I got some things I don't want to be too
positive let's leave that to you guys yes I'll be
the edge Lord what's your negativity Greg oh no
I'm reserving let's get all the negatives out of
the way firsthand yeah get everybody on our side
yeah yeah yeah no I'll I'll I'll I'll reserve
it I'll be the one that [__] douchebags that
have a problem with women are mad at I think
the exact people that need to hear the things
that she had to say are gonna be the exact ones
that get mad at this show and I'm glad they made
it uh I think that like this character has been
around since the 70s oh it's coming but I don't
give a [__] doubling down uh Stan Lee made
this character before he left and came back
to Marvel this was the last character Stan Lee
made before he left and resumed and Stanley was
always about seeking inequality uh justice for
inequality seeking equality Stanley was always
about making sure that people felt like they
were represented and I think She-Hulk somehow
in 2022 is still terrifyingly relevant so I
love the fact that there were examples of how
she would be superior in some ways and that's
going to be the biggest we're gonna see [__]
32 commentary we're going to see all sorts of like
why was she able to beat up the Hulk all of that
[__] and I think it's important to acknowledge
that women do have to deal with anger and emotions
differently and I think it's important to
acknowledge that this is a character based on
emotion they had literally invented the Hulk to be
a force of what rage embodies a man like they they
um I think it was red was the original color
that Stanley wanted Hulk to be but the ink
wasn't as good so it was green and then gray
happened because of a similar like printing
quality issue the Hulk has always represented what
it's like when when you can't control rage and I
love the idea that She-Hulk represents like yeah
they are better at controlling anger than we are
because they have to because society says don't
be emotional woman so I loved the first episode
have you met enough women I don't know any
women because what's a woman they're out of
control they're lying to you Coy that's part of
their master plan to gain control over the world
they're constantly I think they're oppressed I
constantly thinking the way I talk about them
is is It's upsetting no and I'm like cool your
horses ladies yeah just smile a little bit come on
silence
fourth wall breakup silence uh
I just love how you I just love
how you kicked off with that as if that
was gonna be the thing I was gonna say
okay I'm kicking off with the thing that's gonna
be everyone's commentary I'm kicking off what I
think we're gonna see on what Friday this drops on
Thursdays I think we're gonna wake up to Twitter
on Friday saying all the [__] I just said so
I'm kicking it off with like what's gonna be
[__] trending yeah um no I mean that's that's
already happening before this ever it came out
all right yeah it's gonna happen um no I mean I
I do I appreciate the context of that once this
is the first subject I guess we're going there
uh since uh yeah I do appreciate the context of
that I do think that I was having a little bit of
issues with the pacing at first and I kept kind
of like Marvel for giving it that's that's how
I call my forgiveness of Marvel sometimes which
is like this is her narrative she's doing
a flashback story so it's just going by a
little quick for my for my taste it's going by
a little fast and then I did like I don't mind
the context of that at all uh it was really the
parts of the Way It Was Written seemed like okay
so all her angers only based in the fact of
how men treat her of these little things so
some of it felt a little bit I would have liked
to have seen anger be more than just that yeah
I agree with you yeah that was main that was my
qualm with it not like freaking you're throwing
[__] in my face it was more like it's a
little mixed and more layered and I'm sure
that's an aspect of your anger but maybe not the
entirety of Warriors like a corrupt court system
large being problematic Beyond just men in it
like yeah there are others yeah and uh so and so
some of it was moving a little bit faster because
overall there's a lot I liked about like I I think
um and I feel like you would attest uh to this
this is me looping John in the conversation so I
did that guys leading the conversation no I didn't
even notice nobody sits in the middle the was that
um I really love uh Tatiana maslani that's her
name right yeah I think she's excellent I think
the way how they've gotten you know Iman villani
and Tatiana woman Gettys your names so I could
remember them and pronounce them easier why can't
they all be Tessa Thompson yeah it's something
simple yeah like a Jane or something right no
Ahmad Milani and uh Tatiana maslani wow there's
a real ring to those uh I think they've done like
amazing casting with both of them here and she's
excellent like instantly immediately endearing
like you do buy the history that oh yeah she has
been his cousin her whole life right their whole
life they might have met a year ago like we don't
know when like maybe they were friends whether
they could have met a year when the actors met
each other because like they they do embody that
history and they're such a natural chemistry with
them like you were pointing out we were watching
Again Luke and John in was that they have that
that history with each other and I think she
already brings so much life to this character
and I I'm enjoying what they're doing with um uh
like her having this dichotomy that I think is
an actual pretty I think it's a very realistic
dichotomy the way how you had like Spider-Man
like I want to be a teenager and go to school but
[__] I'm a superhero too and then she's already
dealing with that complexity where because like
this is something that just kind of happened to
her and she has to throw her whole life away when
her whole purpose was driven off of her career
especially like a lawyer in Los Angeles like
that's really going to be a thing that I'm this
is everything I've dedicated my whole existence
to and now I gotta sacrifice that like how can I
make both of that work I think that is a really uh
interesting thing to explore I do think in terms
of the She-Hulk side God damn it the second the
thought came I was like no no people are going to
think I'm saying Mary's too I'm not saying that
uh I'm saying that I do think at times it was
come and maybe it's is like this in the comics is
maybe that's the maybe that's my Marvel forgiving
way of doing it guys that's how I forgive all Mary
Sue's out there well I think I personally sources
I think they wanted to get to the lawyer stuff
and not to be a training show she did kind of pick
up on everything a little too quick for my taste
though you know what I mean I don't disagree and
I and I like what you said about more than just
mad at me like there's other things to be mad at
I don't disagree with either of those things yeah
it's interesting I feel like there is hey guys
uh no no I do think that there is a bit of a
bingo card unfortunately that people are going
to be sitting there checking off in their own
little Rage Cage and that was something that made
me wonder because yeah I mean it's obviously like
a very self-conscious aspect of the conversation
surrounding any female-centric con content
anything like this that involves power and it
makes me wonder if they're going to use it in any
way or extrapolate on it later because yeah like
I shared a lot of the same kind of just a little
earmark notes and what you call Marvel forgiveness
I also call like comic book forgiveness there are
certain like you can I feel like in a comic book
specifically you can more sort of easily throw out
like a big outlandish High concept thing and have
it be like oh yeah one Minor Detail in a sequence
of many but uh I want to see what they make out
of that because the strength for me was yeah I
liked all the scenes fast though they were moving
I liked you know the conversations the Rapport
between the two of them like I think this really
sings in terms of character but it does make
me wonder because there are so many things that
people actively whinge about constantly about Mary
Sue's and other things that are all like very much
displayed here in a way where I'm almost like I
wonder if that's intentional partly to rile up the
people who are going to complain about that but
also maybe they will you know use it as something
in the story form to extrapolate upon or something
or at least that's my hope as this goes forward
yeah because right now what I think they've done
a really good job at fleshing out nothing really
external struggles have we really got into because
it's like oh she had a she had an issue to deal
with and seems like she's getting really excellent
handles on the issues really fast in terms of the
physical stuff what they've really done a good job
of fleshing out is her internal all struggles and
to me that is arguably more important I don't even
feel like it's arguably I feel like usually it is
more important than than the physical side
of things like so I really I really like one
aspect of what they're doing I think the acting's
really good I think the comedy for the most part
is is really hitting and I I like the way they've
set up like for if you look at it just as a pilot
I think it's a really set up strong where oh I I
wonder what the journey is going to other than my
trailer knowledge I wonder what like the journey
will be and what it's going to feel like episode
to episode moving forward I really enjoy the fact
that it feels like episodic TV I really like that
some of the Marvel shows have been like we're
gonna be a long movie cut in parts and other
shows have been like we're trying to tell a story
and sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't this
feels like a show and I kept marveling at how
impressive the CGI was uh because the show budget
is you know different between shows and movies
and this is something airing on Disney plus and
I was really impressed at the fact that it looked
like a Hulk like I really enjoyed Hulk on screen
She-Hulk definitely got a lot of improvements
from the trailers and there is an inherent
um uncanny valley to something that has a brooding
brow and stubble and more texture than you know
a Hulk we're used to versus a seven foot woman
that's effectively green like it's harder for our
brains to go like that's almost what a person
looks like versus that's a Hulk and and the
Marvel Mark Ruffalo mapping has had more years
to do it so it makes sense that the Hulk looks
a little more fleshed out pun intended
then the She-Hulk because they've only
had like the six months torque on it we've been
hearing all about the visual effects stuff at
these major Studios and all these things like
developing in real time uh you know there's
some anger there's some frustration oh dude and
they're just they're overpaid at those places
now they're just sitting around listening
just willy-nilly drinking pina coladas
we love you but like how impressive is it like
they announced this show what a year ago we saw
the trailers and there was a lot of like you
know upsetness and now this looks great like I
was impressed I love the way it shot I love the
tone I love the pacing uh there is a little bit
of pacing issue with the speed of the Montage but
I think it effectively set up a show that is now
going to have uh we have the relationship between
Bruce and Jennifer established we've got you know
how much she loves her job and now we can have
a lawyer show and we have this set up for World
War Hulk and maybe the setup no yeah and I think
it uh I mean not to overshadow the theories but
uh but no I think it like as it got into like the
one after the episode you want to talk about the
the actual episode not the future do you want some
Easter eggs there's me there's that there's an oh
yeah break down the finale now if it's not this
I don't like this show these expectations give
me exactly what I wanted there was no Daredevil
at all where's yeah as we got to them I mean I'm
curious about how that stuff is gonna go because
a lot of the Hulk action I thought looked really
good and then the titanium scene at the end was a
little bit like I hope we can kind of make these
action scenes feel as good as those acting scenes
but for the most part the the second half of the
episode felt really smooth and like we reached
this cruising altitude where like it didn't feel
so fast anymore so I'm hoping that yeah maybe
that's just getting used to the pace of the
show overall my three biggest flaws are all and
this is Marvel forgiveness comic forgiveness but
my three biggest flaws are definitely the fact
that she did learn as quickly I like that she
is more Adept but there is a there is an element
of like okay I would have liked to have seen some
pitfalls in the training every time they cut to
her they were like and success I would like to
say something like build up to success just for
like the hero's journey is to learn how to blank
yeah and then I did have an issue with the Titania
fight looking like uh lesser but I also feel like
two CGI characters always gonna look better since
CGI was invented but it was weird that like so I
agree with that being an issue and I don't know
how they're gonna do that with Daredevil because
Daredevil shouldn't be CGI like I hope that you
know what I mean like so that's gonna be a thing
and then then third I do definitely feel like
they at points were making her um only mad at the
audience that is going to be mad at the show but
in a way that it gives them more ammunition like I
I the the MCU crowd has plenty to to yell about I
don't necessarily think that it's good to poke the
bear well that's why I'm hoping that they will use
those things are you talking to the women who made
the show yes the women yes let me tell you guys
how to do your job but no for those people who
are gonna be freaking out they're already gonna
be freaking out it's you see you watch an episode
like this and you think okay so if it's working
this is the thing that makes you upset and that
causes you to take to the internet and you know
harass people you know this episode is probably
going to set you off and repel you immediately to
the point where you're probably not gonna make it
to episode two so it's just a curiosity for me of
what the intent is and what the awareness level
is of that because I think yeah it's like this is
a good place to have some of these conversations
and it's a good character to mix with these you
know experiences and stories you know while in
the high concept setting but yeah like in this
sort of post post-woke post Mary Sue world that
we live in I feel like you almost have to bring a
certain level of additional awareness or else you
are just making it clear like no this show is only
for yeah she was a guy I would have the exactly I
hope whoever's been a viewer of us long enough
now knows that we are being honest when we say
if that was a guy we would have the exact same
qualms yeah and I don't want them to coddle to
[__] by making it anything less because that's
the character but I also don't want a character in
any training montage to not learn yeah it makes it
makes it less interesting and less cathartic and
rewarding it's just like I'm just kind of watching
I'm using stuff now and it's always it's like the
philosophies and stuff and her whole thing about
the reasoning of why she is so adaptable like it
all makes sense and I hope people are able to
see the themes past the surface level stuff
but I think we're going to be getting a different
struggle for her hopefully I've adjusted at this
pretty well and everyone loves me I like law and
Justice and being a home now I'm a very successful
lawyer everything's great everything's great
yeah um and and uh going off the VFX I think that
I think what they really got to handle on with
her um is the when they were like keeping her
a little shadowed when it was really bright like
like we're just out in the bright Sun on a beach
that's when I'm like okay it's it's still like
but I it's not Marvel forgiveness this is just
a VFX artist struggle forgiveness and knowing
everything that's been coming out which seems
to be so compounding at this point I I am like
I'm Not Really Gonna harm it I can tell that's
a She-Hulk yeah like that's nice now it's now
I'm so aware of the conversation surrounding
it that a lot of the time I'm like that looks
good looks good looks good that doesn't look so
good that doesn't look good now looks good it
looks good it looks good damn it that freaking
conversation just going off in my head now when
I'm watching it this gave me the experience I
hoped for where it is like it is in a lot of ways
like a piece of makeup it's like I can tell they
probably there is a performance happening they
use probably the eyes especially to bridge the
gap and yes some sequences look better than others
but even with a great prosthetic sometimes you can
sit there go I can tell it's a prosthetic but
the performance is endearing and all the scene
work is great so you I saw past that pretty easily
yeah because you're a better man than me and I was
aware that women made all the VFX on this show
all women man they can't do it I have no idea
they can't do it that's why the siege takes so
long um anyway guys what did you think of She-Hulk
if you've made it this far leave your thoughts
down below do you think koi is a sexist hashtag
koi's not a sexist hashtag soy koi it's gonna go
so well for me don't worry I can tell most viewers
try to make it this far cry forward to most is
the public discourse surrounding what should
otherwise be a very pleasant experience good show
we'll have nine weeks of content and so will us
or another side of the internet we'll have nine
weeks of content and don't actually watch the show
subscribe leave a like let's do a patreon the day
shout out before we get the hell out of here yeah
all right Anissa Oliva number one Mary Sue at
the Patriots if there's anyone who's a Mary
Sue at our patreon page it's you everything
comes so easy to you you're just so great at
everything you're so smart you don't need to
work hard at all money just you just open up
an envelope like look at all my boatloads of
money you don't have to work two full-time job
wise alcohol at a great sacrifice weekend hours
in order just to freaking pay off some bills or
help out with the family no everything's
as easy peasy Breezy for you everything
that's a nice patreon love you no niece we love
you you're a tough ass cookie you struggle in
our nuanced character too say something nice
Coy I don't know you but I like your name and
you've got a lot of vowels in it that's good yeah
like Tatiana maslani Alexandra or Mark Ruffalo
he's the member if you remember Marvel
actors mark people are gonna think I'm
calling you tits Chris Chris maslani Chris
there's not enough Chris's in the MCU I like
making jokes that are very minimally provocative
I'm just so so minimal and I read the one wrong
comment and I'm like I'm pissed off someone
else hurt their feelings I've done [__] up
all right let's regulate your feelings